welcome back are you and your home ready
for a fresh start
our friends at zero res are here to help
it is a new year and you deserve a
cleaner start to 2021
and that being said there is one word
you need to know that is xerorez
ben mckee the owner of xero res las
vegas has been dedicated to cleaning
vegas homeowner's home since 2004
with products that are environmentally
safe and
technologically advanced i might add hi
ben how's it going mercedes
good now tell us why we need to get back
to clean here in 2021
well at zouarez we've been cleaning
homes and businesses for nearly 17 years
like you said
and we've got this incredible technology
that can out clean
any other competitive carpet cleaner out
there
in fact in laboratory tests they've
shown that we can remove up to 200
more contaminants out of your carpet and
right now that is
especially now people are so worried
about keeping things clean
in their homes and and not bringing
anything in one thing i've actually
learned from you guys is that our carpet
is the largest air filter in our home
it is and for those of us who are
suffering with allergies or asthma right
now
that is the greatest thing you could do
is get your carpets clean because that
carpet is actually filtering all the air
that's passing over it
it's picking up pollen dander pet hair
all sorts of nasty contaminants
and once that carpet is professionally
cleaned it can go back to doing its job
of filtering the air
so all that garbage doesn't end up in
your lungs well now some people might be
a little nervous about
letting people into their homes right
now can you tell us what
xerorez is doing to make us feel safe
and to ease our minds
we wear our proper ppe we have this shoe
covers we have gloves we have face masks
and we're cleaning our equipment
regularly so that you and our team could
be
safe do you do office buildings do you
do workplaces
yeah every day and every night we we
have a dedicated commercial crew
to fit your schedule and what you need
to get done
and they're proficient in every flooring
surface and we use the same technology
and it's been proven that it you know
it's it's safe to use in your home but
it's it's extremely powerful in the
commercial setting
we typically have higher traffic
trafficked areas and
and more soil to deal with well i am
so grateful for all that you guys do and
as usual you
always come to the table with a great
special what do you have for our viewers
today
always so for this new year's we have
three rooms of carpet cleaning that's
pre-treated cleaned
and zebra resified for only 99
and we're going to throw in a free area
of tile and grout cleaning
up to 100 square feet absolutely free
yeah that's right
carpet tile air ducts they do it all
again
don't miss out on that new year special
three rooms of carpet
clean for just 99 plus that 100 square
feet of tiled clean
just give zero res a call 702-840-3333
or go to their website
xerorezlasvegas.com